Samira López: Today’s focus: performance baseline for homepage.
Riley Chen: Any blockers from last time?
Avery Kim: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Jordan Patel: I think we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: Risk: flaky tests for performance baseline for homepage.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Riley Chen: I propose we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Samira López: Let’s not block on performance baseline for homepage; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Action: set up dashboards.
Riley Chen: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: From design side, We might need a migration.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Priya Singh: Quick update on the scope on performance baseline for homepage.
Noah Williams: Any risks we’re missing? on performance baseline for homepage.
Noah Williams: My take is we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Samira López: Risk: accessibility gaps for performance baseline for homepage.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on performance baseline for homepage; start with a spike.
Noah Williams: Quick update on the scope on performance baseline for homepage.
Avery Kim: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: I propose we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: My take is we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Samira López: I think we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for performance baseline for homepage.
Samira López: Let’s not block on performance baseline for homepage; ship a thin slice.
Jordan Patel: Risk: data migration for performance baseline for homepage.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on performance baseline for homepage; start with a spike.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for performance baseline for homepage.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Priya Singh: My take is we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: We should add a feature flag on performance baseline for homepage.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on performance baseline for homepage; parallelize testing.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: I think we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: Risk: data migration for performance baseline for homepage.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Priya Singh: UX needs a final pass on performance baseline for homepage.
Noah Williams: From QA perspective, Security review is likely.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on performance baseline for homepage; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: I propose we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: Action: set up dashboards.
Jordan Patel: I think we split performance baseline for homepage into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: From design side, Specifically for performance baseline for homepage.
Riley Chen: Okay, who can take ownership?
Jordan Patel: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Jordan Patel: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.